from Mike cernovich we have an initial
tweet from J Michael Waller who said not
even the Soviet Communist party did this
type of legal weaponization during its
last years in power
Mike cernovich says right we are in the
early stages where Bolsheviks are
Shoring up power the Cold War analogies
don't hold up we are in the quote the
tsar and his family are massacred phase
of History
I'm curious what you guys think
because obviously uh you know I was I
probably still trending on Twitter I was
trending all day for saying for like the
800th time you were in a civil war but
this one time people were shocked that I
said it oh come on it's a meme
but I I I don't know if Civil War is a
fair way to assess it because we may not
be inactive War as some people describe
it but I think at the fundamental
definition of multiple factions fighting
over control of government you are
certainly in something akin to that and
many people say well maybe it's a cold
Civil War and that's a fair point as
well or it could just be a Bolshevik
communist or Communist Revolution I've
said a bunch of times I think that we're
in the middle of a uh a cultural
evolution in the United States similar
to the one that happened in China so
it's a Communist Revolution a cultural
revolution yeah I know but communist
yeah communities are involved that's for
sure yeah the thing is that it's not
communist like you know back in the day
like the philosophies have evolved so
this is a a you come want to call it
neo-communist or something like that
Neil Marxist that's fine because it's a
new version it's based you know there's
oh there's there it's like there's
multiple different kind of it's almost
like it's a religion one overarching
religion and there's different sects of
it you know what I mean
um so I'm not like I know I've seen on
Twitter there are people that are upset
that you said that and stuff but it's
like like I I've kind of felt like we're
in the in the middle of a a not a an
actual Civil War obviously because
there's not you know
um considerable violence in the street
between warring factions but we are in
an information War isn't there no
there's not like there's not there's not
okay because I'm talking about like
actual gun fights right oh yeah yeah
that's what I'm talking about and that's
and that's what they're that's what
they're the people that are upset
they're upset because Civil War brings
to mind gun fights in American streets
and that's what they don't want people
to be referring to and so I want to be
completely clear we are not in a civil
war because we're not in there's not
gunfights over territory with factions
fighting the United States government
fighting each other there's an
information war going on I agree with
that Civil War cold civil war Civil War
period yes that I agree with but it's
not we're not gun fights we've already
had uh people killed yes we've uh we've
had numerous there's political violence
there's there's occupations autonomous
zones yep uh weaponization of government
one faction yeah one faction arresting
their political opponents all of this
that's why I said earlier today all the
stuff that's happening here people that
are outside of the United States context
outside of the western context when they
look at us and they see oh one political
party is persecuting their opponents
they're arresting people they're
charging as lawyers blah blah they see
that and they're like that is all Banana
Republic and no matter how much
Bill Crystal and the morons the New York
Times want to shove their head in the
sand and swear up and down that America
is different the rest of the world sees
right through their horseshit right
through it because only
unreliable and furthermore again the the
fact that this makes America look
unreliable only hurts the dollar when
it's never been weaker when we've never
had more debt when we've never had a a
well it's been a long time since we've
had this the type of uh income
inequality that we do have in in the US
there are a lot of problems that all of
this stuff only makes worse you know so
I I don't see Stephen Marsh says that
we're in civil Strife which is the
period that occurs right before a civil
war happens civil civil Strife civil
Strife is when you have I think what do
you say like 70 or more per year
political deaths and the US is well
beyond that most people just don't track
these things but what people also don't
realize and I have to say this every
single time
there was a revolution in Egypt two of
them actually within like a span of a
year of each other if if you went to the
mall you wouldn't know anything was
going on and because of this people
watch movies
and they think Civil War means you look
out your window and guys in uniforms are
marching down the street yeah go watch
different go watch the videos of the
Syrian Civil War where you see people
walking around with groceries and going
grocery shopping like people don't stop
surviving and living and doing basic
things like eating food and going to the
grocery store simply because somewhere
there's fighting going on when I worked
for vice we wanted to do this
documentary on Syria this is the like
the peak of the Civil War because in
Damascus they were advertising tourism
in the United States we were getting ads
for Damascus nightlife and we thought
that would be absolutely wild to go to
Damascus and document how people were
just living their lives while there's
like sarin gas attacks happening 50
miles away highways being taken over
people were blowing each other up with
shells and their snipers everywhere but
in the city
you wouldn't have known for the most
part so because of because of I I think
condensed history and movies
people assume that there can't be any
kind of warfare because the average
person is going grocery shopping and I'm
like yeah that's that that's what I
witnessed and every place I've been to
so does the southern border or any of
the crime in any major city any of that
other stuff contribute to the current
Civil War 100 so that's what I was
saying so let's say this because there
is I mean the death that the gun
violence in in Chicago and LA and New
York is kind of Civil War the southern
border I think is the biggest the
biggest component that people should
consider when it comes to the escalation
in the Civil War
let's say that by hard definitions we
are in civil Strife as Stephen Marsh
described it in his book titled the next
civil war he's actually a he described
himself as a multicultural democracy
kind of guy and More in favor of the
liberal world view so be it and he says
we're not quite in Civil War yet civil
Strife let's say that's the case
there's a various scenarios that could
occur which will lead us into full-scale
Civil War and it's not going to be this
ridiculous Clan banging a gavel on a
Podium it's nonsense what it's going to
be is that groups of militia will start
forming on the southern border because
of the crisis you've got an old man
traffickers were crossing his property
they get shot and killed I don't know if
he's the one who did it they arrest him
the guy his own land his own own
property traffickers coming across his
property he defends his property they
arrest him he's gonna go to prison
eventually you are going to have people
say the federal government has abandoned
us there's no law enforcement down here
and the drug and human traffickers are
running rampant
we've already had what do they call
themselves The Minute Men in the past
and various militia groups at what point
do they actually then just assert
territory and all of a sudden
this could already be happening right
now by the way because these stories
have been uh persistent for the past 10
years or so
right now there could be a faction of
people on a certain point of the
Southern border say Arizona Arizona is
probably a good state for it that
there's open board uh barrier-less
border and they don't recognize Federal
Authority because the federal
government's abandoned them like I'll
put it this way they're not actively
planting flags and saying there's no
government they're saying that doesn't
pertain to us I have I don't care they
then start acting on their on their own
behalf what happens when one of these
groups sees someone smuggling children
traffickers which happens a lot all the
time and they stop these traffickers a
gunfight breaks out and they kill these
guys and then the federal government
tries to arrest them
the thing about Civil War is that it's
not going to be people people have this
view of Civil War because of the
American Civil War that it'll be two
factions who will all sign treaties
together in various States will be alike
we're all working together in shake
hands when in reality it's going to be
various factions within States and if
you take a look at how Syria devolved
into Civil War it was various factions
fighting the government and they all had
different perspectives and Views and
eventually started coming together and I
think that was the free Syrian Army I
could be wrong
we could see something similar where you
have pockets you have groups that feel
the federal government is is derelict or
is is uh illegitimate the indictments
against Donald Trump at the federal
level if Trump is removed from the
ballot how soon until sentiment grows in
various rural areas where they're like
we don't answer to you anymore you are
not the government it takes only 10 guys
or so to assert that ideology that world
view that if Donald Trump is removed
from the ballot then whoever's in office
is not the actual government confidence
shatters one of the things I think
they're trying to do with the
indictments is to maintain confidence
that their power is absolute but that
does not work it never works that just
leads to Rapid destabilization the
Soviet Union only that's at 69 years
perhaps we get a Bolshevik style
revolution in the United States
Democrats in their crackpot neo-marxists
gain power and it lasts 30 years who
knows or or maybe when that does happen
you will get various roaming factions of
individuals in rural areas that don't
answer the federal government anymore
and the federal government can't contain
them and starts to ignore them people
need to understand the amount of
Personnel in the federal government is
not large enough to contain widespread
unrest not at the urban level but at the
rural level where people are just simply
saying we don't answer to you or they
put up checkpoints or they just outright
stop paying taxes or something like that
I mean didn't didn't they set up like
what was it Chas a thing remember when
they set up that whole yeah how many
days the autonomous I mean how many days
is that George Floyd autonomous I think
was like a year or two
so why can't why wouldn't that that's
exactly what I'm talking about yeah
exactly I mean you can kind of strike in
a city
I wouldn't put it past them yeah right
imagine what would happen and this is
this is a point James Lindsay makes that
the reaction is the goal that either
they're trying to force you to allow
perverts to groom your children or they
get you to react and claim your hateful
bigots and they use it as justification
that part imagine the inverse imagine a
group of right-wing conservative types
who are peacefully occupying land that
is controlled by the federal government
the bundies for instance remember all
that that he's actually scheduled to go
back to jail I think on Thursday or so
back to jail I just I I don't let me
confirm that but I read that yeah but
and I don't wanna I don't want to
conflate necessarily that was a
different circumstance but imagine
there's swaths of federal land that are
completely you know unused but it's
federal land and a group of guys are
just like we're gonna start utilizing
this we don't recognize the authority of
the government what's the government
going to do imagine they show up and
drone strike as Ian suggests yeah that
reaction will result in more people
having their confidence shattered in
government amen Bundy was a arrested
three days ago for what uh defamation
what and he was released yesterday
defamation that's a civil tort that's
not criminal arrest warrants since
mid-april after an Ada County Idaho
judge found him in contempt of court
confusing to show up to legal
proceedings interesting for nearly a
year so that he just got let out
yesterday can't move property
or large cash sums for two weeks
eventually you're just going to have a
community I mean you look at uh rich men
north of Richmond the viral power of the
song 10 million views in a couple days
wow confidence shattered in government
is what leads to Civil War not a group
of people who are organized and then
sign a document and say we hereby
declare it's when random people just say
you're illegitimate get off my property
I'll put it this way if a guy showed up
to your house let's say you got it let's
say you got an acre in a suburban area
or rural area and one day a guy being
carried in one what are those things
called where it's got the sticks and the
guys carry it and the guy sits in the
middle I don't know yeah let's say
they're like a throne yeah it's not a
throne it's called something else I
don't know a word they're carrying him
Egyptians he says puts me down puts me
down they put him down he walks onto
your property and says you will now
tithe you will you will uh pay me 20 for
I am your king
what
all right what are you talking what are
you talking about no you're not right
what if a guy walked onto your property
flashed a badge and said that he was the
uh the the the Neo Lord declared of the
uh of the current
you know region or whatever you'd be
like wait what like what's this badge
that would be a little bit confusing
most people don't know what a
comptroller is so if someone shows up
with a badge and says they're in charge
a lot of people right now are just like
okay we still do have the United States
people being like look I don't know you
are showing me a warrant but a lot of
people just submit
the point comes when there will be a
legitimate law enforcement officer from
an agency no one's heard of or doesn't
care about or even from let's say like
the FBI and people just don't respect
them because they feel when the FBI goes
after Donald Trump in this way and they
see on news that it appears to be
completely political and illegitimate
they say these people aren't actually
enforcing the law anymore why would I
the only only reason why you'd agree to
do anything they say is out of fear of
death
well there's a lot of people that don't
and that's and that's terrifying they
don't fear death so what happens when
they say uh morbidly OB 70 year old guy
who's posting online that he's going to
take action against the government very
serious ways that people should not do
then they show up to his house what does
he do the latest report on that guy at a
Provo Utah was that he had a loaded 357
Magnum pointed at the federal officers
that's the kind of stuff that I'm
talking about now I want to make sure
I'm clear on this there is a path to
victory that
is through the legal system is by
electing Donald Trump
they can't they're not guaranteed
Victory this is why they're indicting as
lawyers
they want a reaction they want people to
get violent they are desperate for it
because people are shifting towards
Trump trump is winning in the polls in
many states like I said over the past
year or so people went from being
passively anti-trump to passively
anti-democrat uh anti-establishment I'm
not saying they're voting for Trump I'm
saying that they're losing confidence
and they are desperate to maintain it
one of the only ways they get it is if
Trump supporters go nuts so they're
hoping that by going after Trump they
get that you said interesting thing into
that they're not anti-democrat they're
anti-establishment and the establishment
used to be Republican in 2006. it was
George Bush's establishment uh war
mongering party for whatever reason
these business bureaucrats behind the
scenes now snagged onto the Democratic
party super delegates make it nice
because they can just pick their
candidate no matter who gets voted what
and people are tired of it we need we're
having a global Revolution right now of
artificial intelligence of conscious
just the way people think since The
Internet's been developed the way people
interface with each other and and we
need a government to catch up to that
Mike cernovich made a really important
point he said did you know that the
Republicans currently have a comparable
majority to what Nancy Pelosi had when
she was targeting Trump with all of
these with all these proceedings
the Republicans just have to have the
nuts to do something no they have the
Republicans have balls of steel don't
you know don't you understand Kevin
McCarthy has iron-clad testicles people
just don't understand he's not on your
side he is standing in front of your
face with a with a grin smiling
saying I'm here for you
while holding his hand behind his back
with his fingers crossed it takes balls
to look into the eyes of an American
citizen say I'm working for you but
knowing deep down inside you are lying
desperately trying to protect the the
uniparty establishment
yeah I look I I think also there's a
shift to when you start to see
um
what's going on in Hawaii right now and
the negligence of
Joe Biden and how they're responding to
you know the the effort to get them
supplies and money in like the local
government like I think that things that
Joe Biden is also dropping the ball on
is another push for people to be like
yeah I I'm just done with this guy like
Trump comes out with you know a
statement yesterday and does what the
three minute video or something about
Hawaii and people are like why didn't
Biden do this this guy's not even the
president right now I don't know what
the federal response has been exactly I
would like to know um but I feel like
this is like a call up the Navy strategy
where you like mobilize the Navy to
protect and preserve that area of the
United States because not only are
people suffering 1300 people still
haven't been found 70 people have been
declared debt or something like that the
entire city of Lahaina has been burned
to the ground for the most part not only
that it's a National Defense
vulnerability to have a broken area of
your country that's not functioning it's
an easy target so they need to protect
it
while your president is on the beach
he's on vacation I I it's almost like
they're doing everything in their power
and one of the things we talked about a
few years ago is that they want Civil
War so they can abolish the Constitution
because you that's the only way you do
it yeah and there's also a push to I
know that people are pretty aware that
the the definitions of words have been
shifting uh considerably the past you
know five ten years people have noticed
that things don't mean what they used to
mean or whatever and there's there's a
tactic in that too if you can shift the
meanings of the words that are in the
Constitution and the Law changes then
you can change the meaning of the law if
you can get General woman yeah exactly
you know exactly and if the so the the
the thing that was pointed out I heard
James Lindsay talking about this but it
was the uh land dedications that you
hear if you can convince people that
they're on Stolen land then they don't
own that property because it's
illegitimately contained and that means
you're not protected your none of your
rights are protected if you're on stolen
property that means you have no right to
that property anymore more and that and
so now I'm not saying that that's
exactly what's going on that that's the
intent behind it but that could be a
very happy side effect that people could
use to go after people's property you
guys remember John Teeter
we talked about it I don't know briefly
tell me it was back in the 2000s this uh
guy claiming to be from the future yes
oh yeah yeah there's a website and it
was you know Silly nonsense but one of
the things he said was that the country
would fracture into four different
regions controlled by four different
powers Europe would control a faction
China would control the faction Mexico
and Canada would split a faction it
seems to be silly nonsense but I bring
it up because
I don't think A revolution is possible
in the United States because the country
is much too big
that's just it uh you look at what's
going on with with the Biden doj
ignoring Lahaina with him uh with his
son in the corruption
with the doj going after Donald Trump
you're not going to get every state in
this country just to be like well that's
legitimate
average 2024
here's my concern
there's not going to be a definitive
winner this is I it could be like 18 I
think 1876 was the year where they were
like who do we count
and it'll be akin to this why let me ask
you guys why should I assume the 2024
election will be handled better than
2020. I think it would be worse any
reason I would encourage you to not to
assume anything in that regard I
feel like the fact that there's not all
of the issues with covid might be a
reason well they're trying to do that
again though well
we'll see Donald Trump makes a bunch of
claims there's ballot fraud et cetera et
cetera why would I assume the Trump
supporters
would say less
I can't just no the the assumption is
clear there's no wolf ramp as if you
said earlier Phil the likelihood is that
in 2024
you are going to have
insane disputes over who are the
official electors because Trump
supporters feeling slighted from 2020
are going to be out in force with and
I'm talking about lawyers but documents
filed pre during after and then you're
going to have legal challenges to to a
certified slate of electors there's
going to be 300 legal challenges in the
courts that aren't going to be resolved
in time and they're going to go how do
we count uh something that's currently
in legal dispute the judges will have to
just throw all of the lawsuits off the
docket which they can't just do my
assumption is 2024 will be bedlam
I I don't see Democrats and Republicans
just being like well you know let me
know what you think with the ballots and
then we'll see who the president is
you're going to have Mark Elias you're
going to have the nclu you're going to
have various factions on left and right
lodging lawsuit after lawsuit and
various jurisdictions before during and
after the election and then what's gonna
happen is various different news sources
that are at odds with each other will
report various different things and
you'll have people in some areas being
like I'm I'm here in the Democrats one
but the Republicans have electors too
they're they're being the state
legislature certified the Republicans
but the media said the Democrats won
what's going on
no now look don't get me wrong I mean
maybe nothing happens I don't know well
you said earlier that you thought it
would be impossible for a revolution to
occur in the United States and I guess
hold on what I'm saying challenging
because of the size if DC was taken over
by an occupying force and a military
coup Texas doesn't go along with that
that's what I'm saying there's no point
where the entire country just says
Revolution now we're under the under the
rule of Communism when I say Revolution
I'm not always talking about a change in
government
um and format like a government like
from a democracy or from a republic to a
communist state I'm not talking about
necessarily like that it's a revolution
is like a change it means to turn
forward so like a change of of the mind
I know this is like a maoist tactic
we're going to change the minds of the
people and but I do think that can be
done for good as well and it can happen
quickly with the internet I I I have
such a problem with that kind of like
changing Minds because that's that's
main that's trying to manufacture
consent or trying to get everybody on
the same page the the the
the ability that humans have to
influence people is only either coercion
or it's just through argumentation
convincing someone or forcing them but
what about when you perform like you I
saw you singing in front of like 10 000
people or something like that yeah but
there's no gear yeah that's I mean you
can you can entertain people
entertaining people and convincing
people to to believe in in your
philosophy is totally different and and
and the idea that you could get someone
just on a stage to use Charisma to
convince people that's a bad thing too
like I mean because like Hitler was
super charismatic but he was also
genocidal Maniac you know so you can't
just say oh this person makes me feel
good you know like I was saying earlier
today like I but like
My Philosophy is is fundamentally an
Enlightenment philosophy because I
believe that we can we can interact with
reality we can see reality and we can
test things and we can reason proper
results and if we just go by feeling and
just by saying oh this guy really moves
me then then you get you end up with
Barack Obama everybody that voted for
Barack Obama for voted for Hope and
change they were voting with their heart
they were voting I believe in Barack
Obama I believe in people I Believe In
Hope and change because I am hopeful and
we can change things for the better
nobody agreed on what change was nobody
did but everybody felt real good about
it we need to have people so we were
coerced well and we were I mean it was I
don't know some people could say we're
like oh worse but it was like he's cool
he's a cool talker he's a good talker
he's cool he smoked cigarettes outside
the White House yeah I mean this guy is
awesome I could party with him I'm
totally want change I'm gonna vote for
him yes I mean that that is true the
votes for Barack Obama were very much
votes for his Charisma and stuff like
that and it and you know there were a
lot of things that changed from when he
was running to when he was in office and
stuff so you know I mean that that is
true but you still like we need to have
people that we need to be able to reason
not just get wrapped up and we feel this
way and we want to have this kind of
emotional reaction and try to connect
with people and convince them and get
everybody fired up I mean you you do
want people that are motivated that
believe that agree with you but you want
people that have reasoned their way to
their decisions not responded
emotionally you know do you think I I
think and I should say that if someone
could stand up on stage fully
charismatic get everyone's Hearts
aligned and then provide them a
blueprint of strategy technically of how
to solve the system and like put it out
of their hands they've they've
galvanized the populace to focus on an
idea that's outside of the person
that that could spark a a mental a
Consciousness right it's not just the
brain it's it's like a whole full body
you know people start working out they
start eating healthier they start having
kids these are culture I think
everybody's tired I think Americans are
tired they're tired of being lied to by
both sides they're tired of being
constantly gaslighted they're tired of
being promised things tired of being
locked up in their houses and lied to
coerced into doing things that they
don't want I think they're tired and
there's no way to go back to like how
can we get everybody on the same page
Unity we need you're never gonna get
that anymore because of the fatigue it's
just they're just disgusted there's a
war weariness I know I've sensed it for
a decade just the pain the pain
conscious there's the dietary weariness
that comes from overeating or eating
crappy food that knocks your body out
it's hard to wake up in the morning that
fog too much carbs all that crap thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time